Speaker 1: I have video for you today
of two guys who are really confident
that they know a lot of different things and
that they are right about whatever it is they
choose to talk about. I'm talking about Bill
Maher and NFL quarterback Aaron Rodgers. Now,
this is a clip from I believe this is Bill
Maher's newish podcast. And to be very clear,
I think Aaron Rodgers is not a bright guy. And
he said a lot of really wacky things about COVID
and other things. And I also find his entire
worldview completely uninteresting. Bill Maher,
on the other hand, sometimes does say things that
I find prescient and compelling and accurate,
but also Bill Maher, particularly when it comes to
medical stuff, like I remember when I was this is
a really long time ago, I remember an episode of
Bill Maher being interviewed by Larry King, the
late Larry King. And Bill Maher took a position
against aspirin by saying, why would you take
aspirin? Your body is not in an aspirin deficient
state, so why would aspirin ever be the thing to
take? Which kind of misunderstands medication
completely? So he's always been a little weird
on on medical stuff regardless. Here is a clip.
Of Bill Maher and Aaron Rodgers, repeating some of
the most tired lines about science. Sometimes is
wrong, medicine sometimes is wrong. So therefore,
you know, the COVID conspiracy theories should
have been listened to just as much as everybody
else. Let's jump right into this first clip.
Speaker 2: That's my problem with society today,
is why does everything have to be so bipartisan?
Speaker 1: Okay. Now, first of all,
Aaron Rodgers means partizan. He doesn't even
know what he's talking about. He doesn't mean
why do things have to be bipartisan? He
means why do things have to be partizan.
Speaker 2: Like every issue is not a partizan
issue. There's right and there's wrong. There's
things that make sense and things that don't
make sense. You have to toe the line on what
your party's saying to you know, and that's the
only stance you can take. Can you not rationally
have a conversation about things that make sense
and be able to do not be swayed by whether you
vote red or blue? Not in America anymore. No,
you can't. And the to me, the ultimate issue that
should not be political or partizan is medicine.
Health. Yeah. What is more personal than what you
know? You do you to how you want to treat your
body. You know, if the argument is, well, if you
don't do our pharmaceutical answer, then you're
going to risk other people's lives. First of all,
that's not true. That's a red herring argument.
Speaker 1: Well, sometimes it's true and sometimes
it's not. But it doesn't actually relate to the
bigger issue that they're building to. So this
really is hard to follow because it's such a
mishmash of different issues. There's whether
science becomes partizan. And of course, I mean,
look at what's going on with climate science. One
side just denies the science. So you've got that
issue. You then have issues of public health,
you have issues of bodily autonomy, and they're
just mixing everything together with a big dose of
confidence. And what comes out is total nonsense.
Speaker 2: Maybe that's true with other things at
other times, or with this before. They knew
that the vaccine does not prevent infection
and does not prevent transfer. So now that we
know it doesn't do either one of those things,
it shouldn't matter what I do.
Speaker 1: So again.
If you really want to have a nuanced conversation,
this is not accurate. And I'm the first to tell
you that there is this very big period in the
sort of meat of the pandemic, at which point the
variants that were floating around in public were
predominantly not variants that were well-handled
by the original vaccines in terms of infection.
That's absolutely true. Very early on, the first
when the first vaccines came out and you still had
a variant out there that was much more similar to
the original variant for which the vaccines were
tailored. The ability to prevent infection was
very high. And if you're not infected, you don't
have anything to transmit. That was the case early
on, as the variants diverged from the original.
More and more, the vaccines ability to prevent
infection and therefore transmission
declined. And that's absolutely true.
We now have this new vaccine that is tailored to
Macron. And it seems, although we still need more
data, that the ability of that vaccine to prevent
infection is higher. And of course, if you don't
have an infection, you don't have anything to
transmit. So the overarching broad statements
about this don't really help anybody, but
they're determined to moralize about it. And so
they have to make such black and white statements.
Speaker 2: Okay. So that's first. But beyond that.
What could be more personal than how I choose to
treat my body. I mean, like Djokovic can't play.
It's so annoying to me. I'm watching the U.S.
Open now. Yeah. Last night. Serena. Oh, I didn't
see she won. She lost last night. Oh. Oh, well.
But the best player in the men's side can play
and be one of the most fit guys in the world.
That's because we had COVID at least once or
twice. It's it is a come to New York is a complete
compendium of what a Potemkin village, this whole
arsenal of nonsense they've thrown at this disease
is. You know, it's even worse than that, though.
Kyrie Irving attended a basketball game.
Courtside for couldn't play for his team. Right.
Are you. How is that possible?
Well, he attended a basketball game.
And got to watch it in the stands, but couldn't
play on his team because he wasn't axed.
Speaker 1: So understand that this is this is
basically outrage porn because if you sit down,
you go, so what exactly is the point you're
making is the point you're making that science is
sometimes wrong? Well, science, by its nature, is
a self-correcting process. And figuring out where
you were wrong is actually revered and it's
a good thing. So that's not really breaking
news. Is your argument that corporations don't
have the right legally to require vaccination?
Because they do. And so it's just a mishmash
of stuff. It's sort of Herschel Walker like in
a way more coherent to just make people mad, but
it's not exactly completely clear what they mean.
Let's just look at one more clip from this.
Speaker 2: To me, the frightening thing was
never the disease itself. The frightening
thing was how much you could you could get
people so quickly to change their way of life,
stay home, wear mask, you know, don't do as
altruistic at first. It's like, oh, yeah, yeah.
Two weeks to flatten the curve. Right. And then.
Just about. Well, every conspiracy theory came
true. Vaccine mandates, vaccine passports.
Speaker 1: Now, understand, this is again,
more outrage, sowing more fear. What does
it mean that a conspiracy theory came true?
Because there were vaccine mandates. We've
had vaccine requirements in the United States
going back at least to 1903 out of Cambridge,
Massachusetts, if not even be, I believe,
Washington's army. Right. So it it's not a
what does it mean that it's a conspiracy theory
that there were going to be vaccine mandates? We
have all sorts of vaccine requirements. What does
that even mean? But people hear it and they go,
That's right. Aaron Rodgers is
right and I should be furious.
Speaker 2: Right. And it turned into like a way
from doing your job to stop the spread to like,
lockdowns. And that's my whole problem.
Speaker 1: You know, by the way, remember,
the nobody was locked down in the United States.
It's it's an absurd statement to use. Now they'll
go, well, it was effectively a lockdown,
because when everything is closed, most of
didn't close. There was there was no lockdown.
Speaker 2: I grew up in a small town with very
little cases up in Chico, California. But
all the small businesses gone. I mean,
our favorite restaurants in L.A., in New York
and across the country, not just in big cities,
but some crazy percentage will never open again.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and of course, that's absolutely
true. And I think there are many criticisms, fair
criticisms to make about how COVID was handled.
There's no problem with that. But these mish mash
is of so-called open and unfettered conversation.
There are obviously these are perfectly fine.
I'm not saying anybody should be censored,
but they just make people angry without
even knowing what they're angry about.
And that is exactly the way that this stuff
works. Remember that on 919 Monday morning,
we'll be doing the next David Paxman
show one day membership special. Get
on my mailing list at David Pacman dot
com to be notified of how to sign up.